بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا
الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما
بعد سوره
الرعد ان شاء
الله درسنا
موصول
حول ايات سوره الرعد وقد وصلنا في هذه
السوره
العظيمه
الى الايه
السابعه
قد ذكرنا فيما سبق ان هذه
السوره تدور على معاني
اساسيه المعنى الاساسي
الاول حقيقه التوحيد الذي بعث الله محمدا
صلى الله عليه وسلم
به التوحيد انواع كما ان الشرك
انواع
التوحيد الذي بعث الله سبحانه وتعالى نبيه
به هو توحيد
العباده طبعا جميع
التوحيد التوحيد ب مى
ان توحد الله سبحانه
وتعالى في
صفاته ان توحد الله في
اسمائه ان توحد الله في الاعتقاد تعتقد ان
الله هو
الخالق هو البارئ هو المصور هو
المهيمن الى
اخره وهذا جيد لكن لا كمل ولا يقبله الله
منك هذا كله لا يقبله الله منك حتى توحده
في
عبادتك اي تعبده وحده دون ما سواه لا تصرف
نوعا من انواع العباده الى غيره سبحانه
وتعالى ولذلك كان شعار المسلم لا اله الا
الله اي لا معبود بحق الا الله
ولذلك رفض
العرب رفضت العرب ان يذعن بها وان
يقبلوها لماذا لان هذه الكلمه تقتضي نبذ
ما كان يعبد اباؤهم كان عندهم
كبر يقول الله تعالى واذا قيل لهم تعالوا
الى ما انزل الله والى الرسول قالوا حسبنا
ما وجدنا عليه
اباءنا ماذا انزل الله ماذا جاء به الرسول
هو لا اله الا
الله لا معبود بحق الا
الله ف العرب في زمن النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم لم
يكونوا
منكرين ما كانوا ينكرون
وجود الله ولا كانوا يعانون من هذه الشبه
هذه ماخوذه من من جاءت من
اليونان وجاءت
من
الروم وهذه المجتمعات التي قد بلغ الفساد
فيها
مبلغه
حتى مس
بالفطره لانه فطره
الانسان وجود
الله الفطره تقتضي في الانسان ان الله
تعالى موجود لا
محاله وانه فوق وانه في
العلو هذا في الفطره في
الفطر ولذلك
كان فرعون
متكبرا كان متكبر
لكن هو كان مقر هو كان في قراره نفسه يعلم
ان موسى عليه السلام رسول من الله وان
الله قد
ابتعثه ويعلم بمقتضى فطرته ان الله في
السماء والا لما لماذا
قال ابن لي صرحا لعلي اطلع الى اله
موسى هو
يستهزئ لكن علم
ذلك
ب مقتضى الفطره هذهه مركبه في الانسان
فطره الله التي فطر الناس
عليها النزاع ما كان في وجود الله ولا كان
في غالب افعال الله وانما النزاع في عباده
الله وحده دون ما
سواه
لذلك قال قوم
هود قالت عاد لهود اجئتنا لنعبد الله وحده
ونذر ما كان يعبد
اباؤنا وقال
تعالى اجعل الالهه الها
واحدا ان هذا لشيء
عجاب جعل المعبودات معبودا واحدا
فهذا هو المعنى الاول الذي جاءت هذه
السوره لتقريره ولن تفهم القران بشكل
عام فهما صحيحا حتى تفهم هذا
المعنى المعنى
الثاني مثال القران في قلوب البشر
كيفه اذا وصلت ايات القران الى
القلب ماذا كان
اثرها اثر
هذا القران واثر هذه
الايات والمعنى الثالث اختلاف
الناس
واختلاف ما فضل الله به بعضا على
بعض هذا
هو ما تقتضيه حكمه
الله
وكذلك فضل الله يؤتيه من
يشاء ثم فضائل من الله هي مكتسبه يكتسبها
الانسان مثل العلم ومثل
ال انما العلم بالتعلم وانما الحلم
بالتحلم
و هذه الاشياء وثم فض
ليست مكتسبه بل هي محض تفضل من الله مثل
النبوه ايش عله النبوه لفلان ومش لفلان
ذلك فضل الله يؤتيه من يشاء مهما عمل
الانسان فلن يكون نبيا
لله هذه
مساله قد اختار الله واصطفى انبياءه من
بني ادم
وادم عليه
السلام
بين بين الطين
والحياه كما جاء في بعض
الروايات ان الله تعالى كتب النبي محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
نبيا
و ادم عليه
السلام لم يزل طينا
فعلى كل حال هذه معاني هذه السوره فكل ايه
في
تقريرها يقول تعالى ويقول الذين كفروا
لولا انزل عليه ايه من
ربه ويقول الذين
كفروا يعني ما زالوا
يقولون هذا فعل مضارع فعل المضارع يدل على
يدل على
الاستمرار لم يقل وقالوا في
الماضي ويقول ما زالوا يقولون انظروا الى
مناسبه هذا المعنى للايه التي سبقتها يقول
ويستعجلونك بالسيئه يعني العذاب قبل
الحسنه اي قبل الخير والنعمه والرحمه وقد
خلت من قبلهم المثولات اي ذاب الشديد وان
ربك لذو مغفره للناس على
ظلمهم وان ربك لشديد العقاب ويقول الذين
كفروا يعني
هذه حالهم مع الله
وعلى الرغم من ذلك
فيزيدون استهزاء على استهزاء ويقول الذين
كفروا لولا انزل لولا هنا بمعنى هل
هلا هلا انزل عليه ايه من
ربه يعني يطلبون يقولون لولا انزل يعني
هلا اتيتنا بشيء من
الايات عن ماذا يتحدثون الله سبحانه
وتعالى
يقول سبحانه لقد ارسلنا رسلنا
بالبينات فكل رسول
جاء
بالبينات جاء بالايات الداله وفي الصحيحين
من حديث ابي هريره يقول رسول الله صلى
الله عليه
وسلم ما من نبي من الانبياء الا وقد اوتي
من الايات ما مثله امن عليه البشر كل رسول
كل نبي له
ايات
ف ماذا يفهم من قولهم لولا انزل عليه ايه
من ربه قيل
هذه الايه
انزلت في كفار مكه لما ارادوا ان يتعنت
ويعاند رساله النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
فقالوا هلا
جئتنا
بايات كايات الرسل من قبلك مثل العصى
واليد واحياء الموتى الذي كان من شان عيسى
وموسى عليهما
السلام وهل هذا هو مشترط
لا الايات ليست الى الرسل هم رسل
الايات كما ان الايات الحسيه ليست الى
الرسل كما ان الايات المعنويه التي في
الكتاب ليست الى الرسل فكذلك الايات
الحسيه المعجزات ليست الى
الرسل هذه الى الله لذلك مرارا
وتكرارا يقول تعالى قل انما الايات عند
الله عند الله هي لله وبالله
وعنده ليس الي انما انا منذر
فهم يريدون ان ياتيهم بايه على
حسب على
حسب
افتراضه اتي بكذا وياتي بكذا واتي
بكذا وهذا لا
يشترط بل ولا
يصلح ما كان
يحسن بنبي في زمن ومجتمع معين ان ياتي
بايات كانت لزمن ومجتمع اخر ما يصلح
هذا بل الله تعالى لا يبعث شيئا من الايات
المعنويه ولا الحسيه الا بحكمه بالغه ما
في لهو ما في
عبث النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كذلك
ما ارسل نبي من
الانبياء بايه الا واوتي نبينا محمد صلى
الله عليه
وسلم مثلها او خيرا
منها ما ننسخ من ايه او ننسها ناتي بخير
منها هذه في ايات القران اليس كذلك القران
ناسخ للكتب
السابقه وكذلك
الايات فاانز بعض العلماء من هذه الايه ما
ننسخ من ايه او ننسها ناتي بخير منها
ومثلها الم تعلم ان الله على كل شيء قدير
قيل النبي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم ما من
ايه اوتيها نبي من قبله الا واوتي مثلها
او خيرا منها يعني مثلا موسى عليه السلام
فلق له البحر اليس كذلك ونبينا
فلق
له القمر في
السماء كذلك عيسى عليه
السلام كان يكلم الموتى باذن الله اليس
كذلك
وكان من
التابعين وقد قال النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم في حديث عائشه باسناد فيه ضعف لكن اي
حسنه بعض العلماء منهم الذهبي في
السير ان عائشه رضي الله عنها قالت كنا
نقول يعني في عهد النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ليتكلم احد من هذه الامه بعد
موته فكان كذلك في زمن الصحابه رضي الله
عنه ان بعض التابعين بعد ان مات
وبرد
جاءه الغاسل ليغسله
فقال فقال له
استعجل اعجل بي فان لي لقاء مع رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم طبعا هذا الشيء يعني
صعب جدا يتصور
ا
وقوعه الا ان هذه امور
واقعه فوتي النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وامته من جنس جميع ما اوتي اوتيت الرسل من
قبله عليه الصلاه والسلام فعن ماذا
يقولون لولا انزل عليه ايه من ربه
اي على
حسب التشهي
عندهم افعل كذا او افعل كذا كل لك اسقط
السماء علينا كسفا ا اقول لك
اي اجعل لك سلم تصعد به الى السماء وخلينا
نشوفك وانت تصعد الى السماء وعلى فكره ما
بنامن
بيك بعد كل ه الصعود الا اذا رجعت بكتاب
من عند الله هيك بنامن
بك تكبر هذا
تعنت
ف هذا
قصدهم فقال تعالى ردا عليهم انما انت
منذر
انما هذا
للحصر يعني ينحصر امرك مع هذا النوع من
الكفار الانذار انما انت
منذر يعني لامثال هؤلاء والانذار هو
الاعلام مع
التخويف
تخوفهم الاصل في الوعظ التخويف ولا
التشويق التخويف هذا هو
الاصل لان اكثر الناس ينفع معهم ماذا
التخويف اكثر من اي شيء
اخر
لذلك
قال
قوم قال العلماء من قوم
قارون قالوا ويلكم ثواب الله
خير ويلكم هذا
تخويف لان الانسان يفهم الخوف كل الناس
يفهم الترغيب لكن كل الناس يفهمون
الخوف فيقول تعالى انما انت منذر ولكل قوم
هاد ولكل قوم هاد هاد يعني
هادي وقرات
سبعيه في قراءه سبعيه باثبات
الياء باثبات الياء وحذف
الياء ولكل قوم هاد ولكل قوم هادي في
الوصل
والفصل وفي قراءه حفص ولكل قوم
هاد
و من هو هذا الهاد الهاد يعني الذي يهدي
يهدي قومه
ينذرهم ياتيهم برسالات الله واياته من هو
هذا
الهاد اختلف اقوال الصحابه رحمهم رضي الله
عنهم في هذا فقال
بعضهم انما
انت يا محمد
منذر ولكل قوم
هاد يهديهم يعني الله سبحانه وتعالى انت
تنذر ولا تست ان تهديهم هدايه توفيق وانما
ذلك الى الله فهو يهدي من
يشاء وقيل ولكل قوم هاد يعني لكل قوم نبي
من الانبياء
يهديهم
والظاهر الاول
اقوى انما انت
منذر فانه
حصر حصر وصف النبي النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم في هذه الايه على الانذار ثم اثبت
الهدايه قال ولكل قوم
هاد والهدايه اشمل من مجرد الانذار
اذا ولكل قوم هاد يعني الله سبحانه وتعالى
هو هادي كل قوم على حسب ما تقتضيه حكمته
لا هادي سواه سبحانه وتعالى
فانت تنذر والله يهدي من
يشاء ثم اخذ يصف هذا الهادي سبحانه وتعالى
فقال
الله ولكل قوم هاد الله
يعلم الله يعلم ما تحمل كل
انثى وما تغيض الارحام وما تزداد
وكل شيء عنده
بمقدار عالم الغيب والشهاده الكبير
المتعال الله يعلم ما تحمل كل انثى يعني
في
الرحم وما تغيض اي تنقص او
تنقص
الارحام
وما تزداد يعني وما يزداد في هذه
الارحام الله يعلم كل ذلك سبحانه وتعالى
وكل شيء
عنده بمقدار يعني بقدر انا كل شيء خلقناه
بقدر يعني
بتقدير ما في شيء زائد ولا ولا شيء في خلق
الله كل شيء
باتزان بديع
عظيم لا يستطيع
تصوره
الانسان من دقته
وشموله
ف قوله
تعالى وكل شيء عنده
بمقدار الان ربنا سبحانه وتعالى في الايات
المقبله سياخذ
اركان الايمان
جاء جبريل عليه السلام في صوره
رجل شديد بياض الثياب شديد سواد الشعر لا
يرى عليه اثر السفر ولا يعرفه من الصحابه
احد
وساله عده
اسئله منها اخبرني عن الايمان قال ان تؤمن
ان تؤمن بالله وملائكته وكتبي
ورسله واليوم الاخر وتؤمن بالقدر خير
وشر حديث
معروف
نعرفه معروف لدينا ف الان في
الايات القادمه س ياخذ ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
في ذكر هذه
الاركان وهي ابرز معالم الايمان
وهذه الاركان التي تسمى اركان الايمان عند
العلماء وهي كذلك فانها
ابرز ما عرف المؤمن من غير
المؤمن بهذه الاركان
وبهذه
الايمانيات المؤمن كيف يعرف ي يؤمن بهذه
الامور ويؤمن بها
على على هيئتها
التي امر الله سبحانه وتعالى فهو
يقول وكل شيء عنده
بمقدار ما تغيض الارحام يعني ما
تنقص وما تزداد وكل شيء عنده بمقدار بعض
الناس قد يسال يقول
اليس هذا
مما يستطيع معرفته الانسان الان يعني
يعلمون ينظرون الى ما في الرحم كان شيئا
خافيا على
الناس امدا
طويلا ولكن الان مع الاكتشافات
والتقدم
تكنولوجي اصبح الانسان يستطيع ان ينظر في
الار
فكيف يكون هذا من علم الغيب اليس هذا من
علم الغيب الذي اختص الله تعالى به
وتفرد
والجواب عن هذه ستاتي ان شاء الله تعالى
سياتي ان شاء الله تعالى غدا ونكتفي بهذا
القدر والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد
كر سوره
الرعد
‏we
arriv ver
سهر for us ourselves remember in
mind قران سوره
الرر
‏acc رضي الله عنهم
all
time
place صل الله عليه
وسمج
chapter it means
was the prop صلى الله عليه
وسلم
مد
صلى الله عليه
وسلم is is cri
because
the type of people
ched people not
people even
tyeb
ched as the people
me
‏andina they aure of idol and they aure
of jews and other
ands is
was and was in we three m fa we musl we
people
‏and and they
all and they ac isam a more differ the
people of
me the
dial
and
and قران all
ch م
مدين so this is
chap
صل الله عليه
وسلم
all
قران around what
is
main the
main
them
قر
‏this
chapter along the maor all chapters
around three main points three main
issues number
one the
type محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
of
re
weis
‏means
one bel
godis transl
for in engl langage
theis
means than do
langage
[Silence]
الله eng
monism being that is taken
from the original concepts are larg
discussed in our culture from gre and
romans and so for
‏it means something very different monis
in english it me bel in one
creat and this is a little
b very limiting to the meaning of
تحيح
bel
people
الله سبحانه
وتعالى most
people
is that
disb
exence god
is of the creat but worship
that
‏until he
worships any partn that is
ep
monism and
so this chapter
revolves
number
‏it's
veracity it's
impecable
eff on the human
heart
specifically that is that most of what
is mention in this book in this chapter
is about or is parable
قران الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
سبحانه
وتالى سبحانه
وتالى
‏because every sle
ver in this chapter is to have a of
that a this one that
and in this chapter all
the
صحح
ملم بخاري
مصحح مم
عمعم صلى الله عليه
وسلم
‏tr approached prop الله عليه
وسلم very
close and he said tell me about
islam the صل الله عليه وسلم
resp isam you tes n is wor الله محد of
الله est
pray
‏make mra
page the house
of to
so he said tell
mean belief he said that you believe in
allah
his that you believe in allah his angels
his books his messengers the last day
and you believe
iny decree of allah
‏the good of it and the bad of it all of
these
six pillars of
fai bel in belief in angels bel in the
bs bel in the messengers belief in the
and belief in decree of allah all them
are
be andell upon in theer of this chapter
we will there and continue tomorrow ان
شاء الله والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا
[Silence]
محمد
‏l